you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
oil gas and coal developments need to
stop immediately if the world is to
reach net zero by 2050
according to the international energy
agency
six months on from the government's plan
for a green industrial revolution we
hear what progress has been made
in an exclusive interview with the
business secretary quasi quatting
and everyone's talking about pete we
hear why it's so important in tackling
climate change
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions because solutions are going to
be key to keeping
this number here below 1.5 degrees now
this shows
the level of human-induced global
warming since the industrial revolution
and as you can see it's ticking out the
whole time
global warming of more than 1.5 degrees
celsius could potentially expose the
world
to more extreme weather greater economic
losses
lower crop yields higher sea levels and
greater damage to wildlife and to
habitats
in order to limit that warming countries
need to take immediate action
radically changing the way energy is
produced used and transported
that's the view of the international
energy agency which has set out more
than
400 milestones the world's energy sector
needs to meet
if we're to stand any chance of reaching
net zero emissions
by 2050. so they say that investments in
new oil and gas projects
need to stop immediately and no more
coal-fired power plants
can be built if emissions are to be cut
to the level that many countries have
committed to
the iea recommends that by 2035 cars
with internal combustion engines
should no longer be on sale anywhere and
by 2040 the entire electricity sector
should be net zero powered entirely by
renewable sources well earlier i spoke
to the executive director of the
international energy agency
fatih birol and asked him to explain
what needs to happen
if the world is to reach that net zero
target by 2050.
number one we have to make
the most out of the existing
clean energy options such as
solar wind electric cars
energy efficiency we have to make the
most out of them
this is number one number two in
parallel to that
we need some other technologies clean
energy technologies which are under
development
but not yet part of the market today
such as hydrogen
such as advanced battery technologies we
need them
especially to decarbonize
the sector such as iron steel cement
aviation trucks we need
this new technology this is the second
one third
we have to drastically reduce the use of
fossil fuels oil gas and coal
broadly this three important categories
need to be addressed and the way doing
this
is through investments investments in
clean energy technologies is the uk
wrong in your view not to have banned
then new oil and gas exploration in the
north sea
i mean uk government is
making exemplary steps to be honest with
you
when you look at what they do at home
and then with
what they do outside and whether or not
governments in uk in u.s europe
china indonesia if they
still give licenses
for the coal or oil or gas
investments or exploration this in my
view
poses two challenges number one
whether or not they contradict
with their own domestic climate coils
is number one and number two as i said
a the we need to
reduce the oil use gas use
coal used drastically and some of those
oil production gas production coal
production
investments may vary be drunk
investments
and the governments or companies may
then lose uh money
uh as a result of uh such uh investments
so that's what the international energy
agency thinks governments
should be doing but what's the reality
well back in november
the uk government announced a 10-point
plan for a green industrial revolution
the aim is to build back better from the
coronavirus pandemic
support green jobs and accelerate
progress towards reaching
net zero well joining me now from
westminster is the business
secretary quasi quattang hello to you
first of all i want to get your reaction
to what the iea is saying they're
talking about
how action is needed now if emissions
targets are going to be reached they say
there should be no
investment in new fossil fuel supply
projects
so will you commit to a ban on new oil
and gas exploration in the north sea
we're not going to commit to it because
as you know there are 250 000 jobs
but what we are committed to is
affecting a transition and that's why
uh i negotiated to help to negotiate a
transition deal
uh and we published that transition deal
it's called the north sea transition
deal
in february and it was well widely uh
received uh in uh
well-received indeed and dr beryl was
quite right i mean
he was good enough to say that the
measures of the uk government are
exemplary that was the word he used
because other countries around the world
are looking at our 10-point plan
they see the fact that we've taken coal
off
the electricity power system um and they
think that we're we're
taking steps in the right in the right
direction does that mean that we
we shouldn't uh increase our efforts
uh no we have to increase our efforts we
have to do
this better and faster but i think we're
going in the right direction and it was
very clear from
dr beryl's words that he he shares that
view
so six months since that 10-point plan
what concrete progress can you report
so one of the things that i was very
pleased to do was only a few weeks ago
go up to t-side which was declared as a
free port
and in t site ge renewables
who make wind turbines for offshore wind
farms
they've announced 142 million pound
investment
and something like 500 jobs that will be
created
directly from that only today they've
announced the number of jobs that they
think they can
that they think they can create from it
uh we've already
uh committed to a fourth auction round
for offshore wind
we have something like 35 percent of the
global capacity global
uh worldwide capacity offshore wind is
here in the uk
uh and that we want to build on that
success so there are lots of things that
we're doing
uh that i think will uh will drive uh
the global move to net zero
quarter thank you thank you in today's
other climate news
just 20 companies are responsible for
producing more than
half of the world's single-use plastic
according to the plastic waste makers
index
the report lists exxon mobil dao and
cynopek as some of the biggest sources
of plastic food packaging and bottles
despite the environmental impact of
single-use plastic production is set to
grow by
30 percent in the next five years
supercar brand lamborghini will debut an
electric model by 2030.
the company also says it will invest 1
billion pounds to electrify
some of their existing models with aims
to reduce co2 emissions by 50 percent
by 2024. chief executive stephen
winkelmann says the change is
necessary in a radically changing world
[Applause]
and leonardo dicaprio is donating more
than 30 million
pounds to restore the galapagos islands
the actor has partnered with
conservation charity
rewild to help endangered animals and
protect the island's wildlife
they aim to reintroduce 13 locally
extinct
species including the pink iguana and
the floriana
giant tortoise arnold schwarzenegger
wants people to have a better
understanding of what cop 26
is all about the terminator star has
been speaking to the summit's president
alok sharma
about this year's climate conference in
glasgow it's part of a new monthly web
series called
arnold's stantish in which arnie talks
to environmental leaders around the
world
so how do you feel about being the
president of something that everything
you've done up until now everyone knew
what it is and now people
say i don't know really what it is well
i i think by the end of this year so
we're going to have this event in
glasgow as you know in november
and i very much hope by the end of this
year everyone does know what this is
because
uh you know this is about tackling
climate change and that is
the biggest challenge i feel that is
facing humanity
right now and you can see more of
arnie's chat with alok on our website
just head to skynews.com climate
now the government has announced plans
to restore peakland
increase tree planting and set a legal
target to stop the decline of nature and
wildlife
it's all part of plans to tackle the
climate crisis and help reach net zero
emissions by 2050.
well in a moment we'll hear more about
plans to treble tree planting in
england but first let's look in more
detail at those plans to ban
the sale of pete compost by 2024. our
science correspondent
thomas moore is here now so thomas tell
us more about pete
well pete is one of the unsung heroes of
the climate story it
stores three times as much carbon as the
same area of woodland
and that's because the plants that grow
in these boggy areas don't fully
decompose when they die
they just get buried in the waterlogged
soil now in the uk we've got 12
of our land area covered by peat and it
stores
3 billion tons of carbon and if it was
in a healthy state could
it could to store another three million
a year sucking that carbon out of the
atmosphere
the problem though that a lot of it is
being drained or is damaged
to make way for lifestyle crops and
conifer plantations
and that means that as the peat dries
out it's releasing
20 million tons a year of carbon back
into the atmosphere
so instead of being a carbon sink it's a
carbon source
and the government's recognized that the
environment secretary today
said that there will be a pete action
plan and as you say
uh pete compost will be banned uh in
garden centers from 2024 in england
and it's also funding the restoration of
35 million
uh 35 000 hectares of pete
in in the uk thomas thank you
well as well as the plans to ban pete
the government has also announced that 7
000
hectares of new woodland will be planted
every year by 2024.
and a new multi-million pound fund will
provide more incentives for landowners
and farmers
to plant and manage trees as becky
cottrell reports
[Applause]
these young trees are set to become a
vital part of this farm's ecosystem
small willow saplings are being planted
not in a wood
but in a vegetable field this is
agroforestry
we all know that trees capture carbon
but they're also
a massive tool for farmers they can
provide you
extra crops above your vegetable crops
such as apples and pears and things like
that like we do here
but they can also they provide wind
protection for my crops
these trees don't just capture emissions
they also attract songbirds
that get rid of the insects that attack
the crops meaning there's no need for
chemical pesticides
so planting here is efficient
sustainable
and it makes financial sense the
government hopes giving out agroforestry
grants
will help to meet their planting targets
about 20
of our countryside needs to be
repurposed for
climate uh uses the great news about
using trees in woodland to capture
carbon
is that they can also be landscape and
nature friendly
support wildlife support farming and be
a beautiful part of our countryside
ministers campaigners and many
landowners say farms need to be used to
reduce
emissions but growers like andy worry
food production will be driven abroad
to meet planting targets at home unless
farmers are given the support he says
they need to help us become carbon
neutral
becky cottrell sky news gloucestershire
that's all for today coming up tomorrow
the eden project in cornwall starts
drilling for hot rocks to generate
geothermal energy
thanks for watching see you then
you